hallo tag ich bin luca ich bin der mit
dem scheiß schneidet acta alter hannover
namens luca und etwas tragisches
passiert ihr seht schon die kissen da
hinten sind alle falsch rum
der held unter meinen videos hat
zugenommen und allgemein ist der hass
gerade allgegenwärtig
das leben ist nicht mehr so wie es
einmal war und viele leute machen
einfach auf die missstände in unserer
heutigen gesellschaft aufmerksam dass in
form von zeitungsberichten blogs im
internet oder unter anderem auf youtube
videos und so als auch in meinem fall
einige quellen die anonym bleiben
möchten haben mir zugetragen dass es
bald mit meiner karriere hier auf
youtube vorbei sein könnte obwohl sollen
grün zurück diese anonyme quellen sind
auf ein propagandavideo auf dieser
plattform hier gestoßen welches ich euch
wirklich nicht vorenthalten möchte
deswegen schaut einfach mal selbst ja
was geht ab alter rauchverbot natürlich
am start war wir die arme kurs dieser
heftigen da wurden hält video gegen mich
aufgenommen
da will ich heute darauf reagieren mir
wurde dieses video irgendwie angezeigt
am rand buy empfohlen und das hieß die
heißt es nochmal ansage an contractor
dem ich habe keine ahnung wieso alter
dem und nicht denen schrei mannschaft
nur mega des hochgeladen von dem user
rauchverbot
er hat auch eine sehr stattliche likes
und dislike anzahl
aber okay wir fangen jetzt mal anschauen
und ein video an heutige jetzt eine
ansage die contrada di sa ich hasse den
ich hasse den magen ich weiß nicht warum
du mich hasst aber ich glaube das wirst
du jetzt gleich sagen ich hab mir seine
videos reingezogen paar alter paar
videos mann und auch sehr witzig mit
seinen scheiß schnitten du hast ein paar
videos vor bereich gezogen und denkst
dass ich nicht witzig fühle weil ich
schneide in welchen bestimmten schnitte
schnitte da schlägt ihr hier steht sie
da steht das schlechte in ein kopftor
okay also du meinst wirklich präzise
gesagt die schnitte auf einem kanal
schnitte hier schnitten schritte meinem
kopf also an dieser stelle ganz kurze
information für dich also ich weiß nicht
wie ich dir das jetzt beibringen soll
aber jeder videomacher schneidet jeder
hast du also jeden gewiss ich witzig mal
du bist einfach nicht witzig schneidet
acta alter aber freundchen ich schneide
nicht um witzig zu sein sondern um das
video zu kürzen die sonne raw datei ist
jetzt wieder 14 minuten lang wenn ich
dir so hoch laden würde wird mein video
so aussehen wie dein und sowas will ich
halt nicht hochladen video vom
rauchverbot ist jetzt also bei mir so
dass wenn ich nicht bei leuten vorstelle
das quasi so abläuft hallo tag ich bin
luca ich bin der mit dem scheiß
schneidet acta alter wir machen wir
weiter mit dem video meine frisur weißt
du was das krasseste wieder ist oder was
gerufen wohnhafte ist bei ihm also ich
muss wirklich sagen fand das video
bisher relativ unterhaltsamen wenn du
deine rolle gespielt hat weil man sieht
dir einfach an dass du eine liebe person
bist du kannst nicht ein aufhielten oder
aggressiv tun ich mein dicker du hast
sogar hintergrund noch seine kinder
tapete also tun ich einen auf böse oder
so und sagt nicht das wort [ __ ] vor
allem nicht bei leuten die du nicht
kennst aber okay freunde ich lasse jetzt
ausreden ich mich interessiert jetzt
auch ehrlich gesagt was er meint was du
[ __ ] haffter mir ist es mit
minecraft das [ __ ] heftige das
[ __ ] heftiger mir ist es sich
minecraft spiele ich weiß nicht kannst
du dich da vielleicht mal wiederholen es
nicht einfach minecraft ich meine
sich wirklich ab fakt dass sich
minecraft spiele dann guck dir meine
videos nicht an aber wenn es dich so ab
dass du mich rufen so nennen muss und
meine familie beleidigt dann solltest du
vielleicht mal zum arzt gehen oder duran
ok freunde ich mir jetzt kooperativ
mister rauchverbot
was würdest du mir empfehlen meine
fresse hilft einfach den kanal ich soll
also meinen kanal löschen
habe ich das richtig verstanden lässt
ein kanal moment so etwas typisches wäre
es noch wenn er sagen würde meine fresse
alter meine fresse alte okay also ich
soll also mein kanadischer flash lite
scheißdreck an ein okay ich hab selbst
verstanden werde ich machen
aber jetzt macht eine direkte ansprache
mich congo after man ja herr rauchverbot
möchtest du mir irgendwas sagen weg mit
dir weg mit dir einfach wie wir wollen
dich nicht mehr weg ich will die
rechtlich zu nahe treten aber du hast
auf deinem video 19 like sooo 849 discs
und hätte sogar nur 18 leicht wenn ich
das video nicht geleitete wie schon so
oft in ihrem video gesagt ich verhalte
mich kooperativ wie kann ich das wieder
gutmachen ist ein kanal bitte nach
diesem video lässt ein kanal dann ist
alles gut sehen wir uns nicht nie wieder
die wir uns nicht wieder wir haben uns
aber gut dann macht über die
verabschiedung von seinem video alles
klar ist auf jeden fall eine schöne hat
die leute zu verabschieden so
zusammenfassen kann ich dazu eigentlich
gar nicht mehr viel sagen ich hab halt
dieses video entdeckt und hab mir
gedacht
der sucht aufmerksamkeit wenn sein
einziges jedes dann gebe ich sie ihm
halt wenn ich das ganze gefallen hat
will ich nicht immer eine bewertung
freudig verlinkt euch mal sein video und
in der beschreibung bitte meldet ist
nicht ich will dass das online bleibt
ich fand es echt unterhaltsam wenn ihr
jetzt gerade noch dran sein kommentiert
mal das video mit dem wort hayta mich
interessiert einfach wie viele leute das
video bis zum ende schauen folgt mir auf
musical wie instagram selbstständig
heißt er überall laser luca und ich
wurde sogar heute gefeatured bei music
ally aber ich hoffe